قال سليم بن حميدان الدكتور في القانون
والمحامي في فرنسا الى الوثائقي ما خفي
اعظم كشف كثيرا من الحقائق بالادله بخصوص
ان العمليات الارهابيه التي كانت تجري في
تونس عمليات موجهه كما قال وداع حميدان في
لقاء مع الجزيره وكيلا الجمهوريه في تونس
الى فتح تحقيق مع من قدم التحقيق ضدهم
قرائن ومنهم وزير الداخليه السابق لطفي
ابراهيم وعصام الدردوري
في الحقيقه هذا الوثائق الليله هو حدث
مدوي حدث كبير جدا كثير من الحقائق كانت
لنا عليها قرائن وتاكد في هذا الوثائقي ان
العمليات الارهابيه او اغلب العمليات
الارهابيه التي حدثت في تونس كانت
احداثا موجهه عمليات موجهه
ساهم فيها
اطراف خارجيه تبين الطرف الخارجي الليله
بعلاقته ربما بمخابرات اجنبيه وبدول
الاجنبيه
كذلك ظباط امن
ومسؤولون امنيون فاسدون لا زالوا يتمتعون
بكامل حريتهم وخارج دائره الملاحقات
القضائيه رغم قوه
قرائن الادانه